heike ich habe mir vor ein paar tagen
mal ein paar ladykracher staffeln auf
dvd angesehen und da nicht mehr
aufscheinen dazu ziemlich oft der beruf
sei vom staffel und da wollte ich mal
fragen wie und wo du das gelernt hat und
ob du uns youtube-nutzer mal eine kleine
kostprobe dieses talent geben könnte
vielen dank das war meine frage
hat er schon mal super ist das als
talent
tituliert wird ok jetzt kommt meine
antwort
ich habe das rülpsen nicht irgendwo
gelernt sein ich hab's mir vermutlich
selber bord wie jeder das hört man
vielleicht mal irgendwo und gibt es dann
oder man macht es aus versehen und merkt
dass gelacht wurde und
versucht das zu perfektionieren ich
brauche dafür einen leeren magen und
viel wasser hier ist pure was ist
schlecht ich brauche stimme ist oder
sind die naturell
ja und dann kann ich das herstellen das
würde ich nur jetzt ungern machen weil
das ein über eine länge also mich über
eine längere zeitstrecke verfolgt man
selbst dann im anschluss noch ein
bisschen weiter weil man weil ich zum
beispiel viel luft so runter würde und
so zu einem so zu sehr tollen holz
ankomme
ich hab sie dann so ein bisschen vorher
brauche ich brauch immer noch ein paar
sekunden
ist dann auch nicht immer an beim ersten
tag gleich gut was ich manchmal ein
bisschen anlauf nehmen was auch sehr
lustig ist wenn das ganze team darauf
wartet man kommt denn jetzt endlich der
perfekte holzer aber
naja also so aus dem aus dem stegreif
geht es nur so mittel das er ist echt
mickrig
mit mit einem halben liter wasser wer
das der perfekte roger geworden